Palmade et la rien à en prison
c'est la meilleure décision possible
c'était de le mettre sous bracelet
électronique dans un hôpital
psychiatrique spécialisée pour les
addictions alors personne va en prison
alors si quelqu'un qui se qui se drogue
et qui prend le volant en sachant qu'il
est drogué qu'il est sous médicament tue
des gens donc c'est pour moi c'est pas
homicide involontaire c'est homicide
volontaire si lui va pas en prison
personne va en prison donc on va nous
expliquer qu'un type qui a fait un AVC
qui fait 12 kg et qui aura à brasse
électronique chez lui va prendre de la
coke sa bagnole sachant que son bracelet
sonne au bout de 32 secondes sa bagnole
et repartir rien ne tient la mauvaise
justice elle est pour lui parce qu'il
est connu s'il était pas connu il serait
pas en détention aujourd'hui pas du tout
changer les choses il faut que les gens
soient responsables il faut que tu dises
que quand tu as pris de la cam et quand
tu es drogué quand tu es alcoolisé que
tu es dans ta maison il faut pas
conduire prends un chauffeur assieds-toi
derrière pourquoi il a pris le volant
merci pourquoi il a tué des